but the memories will come back
eventually and they did
and she
eventually had enough memories to fill
19 pages
and I helped her to correct the grammar
and uh
sentence structure because because of
all the abuse she suffered her her
written English wasn't too good
but
she eventually managed to put it all
together 19 pages
and went to the police the police had
investigated
but then eventually closed it down
and claimed that there wasn't enough
evidence
uh
sorry they investigated and then they
referred it to the CPS now this was one
of those cases where the police did
their job
referred it to the CPS who are the
prosecuting body but the CPS the crown
prostitution service claimed that wasn't
enough evidence so they refused to bring
it to court
so the whole thing collapsed then the
second time when she tried when she had
more memories and tried to get the
police to reopen her case
um I helped her
with the spelling and the syntax of her
statement that was 19 pages long
and went back to the police
but because the police had had a
negative response from the prosecutors
in the past
they were reluctant to reopen and refuse
to reopen the investigation
of course if there's more memories
coming in more evidence coming in in
future
she could probably get them to
investigate again
but at that time at least they were not
willing
to to reopen the case
but this is a case of the police
at least trying to do that job
but the CPS being too quick to to refuse
to prosecute uh the case
and I think the police should have at
least reopened the investigation but she
went back on the second time because she
had more new evidence based on on new
memories that she had since then have
you heard of Bohemian Grove
yes I have
are you is there Satanic rituals going
on there what's going on in Bohemian
Grove I've Heard lots of crazy crazy
conspiracy stories about it but I'm
interested to hear your take on it what
I've heard of Bohemian Grove is that
there are Satanic rituals occurring
there
uh
that a lot of influential people
including people who are going to become
U.S presidents
go there
um
there is this strong implication that
powerful people involved in SRA
are using Bohemian Grove as a place to
meet
uh and to do SRA
because my main focus is on the UK right
I haven't
spent time focusing on Bohemian Grove
uh we have our own similar situations in
the UK right uh what we call VIP abuse
um
the
my take on Bohemian Grove is probably
we need a good investigative journalist
to really dig deep or good private
investigator to really dig deep on the
allegations
to uncover
what's really been done there and what's
going on
uh I think that as in the UK where we've
had a former prime minister involved in
satanic abuse
and
a number of government ministers named
by Satanist ritual abusers is being
involved in SRA
you probably have a similar problem in
the U.S
I'm pretty sure that that's the case
because this is all part of building the
new world order if you want to build a
new world order
with Satanism at its call
you have to recruit people who are in
government in Civil Service in
Parliament or your U.S equivalent of
Parliament
um
because you need these people on your
agenda
so
I would not simply dismiss it as a
conspiracy theory I would
I would see it as as a lead that needs
to be followed up that needs to be
investigated more thoroughly
um yeah probably I suspect Witnesses out
there who can reveal more about what's
going on about
Bohemian growth but of course you have
to gauge the reliable reliability of the
witness yourself
um this is why Witnesses have to appear
uh at the very least by video link if
not in court in person in front of a
jury so the jury can gauge is this
person telling the truth or not
so I always
want to meet the SRA survivors that I'm
helping face to face to gauge their
reliability
um they they may be deluded or they may
be lying I don't know I need to read
them face to face and interview them
face to face so that always helps in any
investigation have you come across any
that were just full of [ __ ] or were
lying to you trying to make up stories
about satanic abuse
I I have
I have from time to time come across
people who claim to be SRA survivors who
I think are not reliable
uh it is not necessarily the case that
they were lying it could be that they
were mistaken
uh there is one SRA Survivor I know of
whom I read his statements she's not in
the UK she's in another country Another
Western Country not the US
and when I read the statement I thought
can't be true
this woman is either
deeply mistaken or
probably more likely
trying to get attention trying to get
attention uh
because she was overdoing it
she was accusing practically anybody and
everybody who's been a celebrity of some
sorts as having abused and I thought no
that just doesn't fit in with the the
more because I've seen a lot of
authentic statements
and this just didn't fit in and there
was something wrong about this
um and I later had
various contacts of mine who had met
this person
confirming to me that this person is not
to be trusted
so my suspicions were confirmed by
contacts who I experienced on this issue
having met the person
face to face and and found that the
person was not to be trusted so these
are a very small number I must emphasize
very small number the majority the vast
majority are
sincerely trying to expose the truth
sincerely trying to have their true
stories believed
so a few bad apples do not spoil the
barrel as the saying goes and um
we
while having to to be alert to this
possibility we should not assume as a
lot of people do that
most SRA survivors are deluded or lying
or mentally unstable that's wrong most
SRA survivors are people whose honest
people who suffer terribly and are
trying to tell their stories so as to
protect children many SRA survivors have
a very
um honorable objective of wanting to
protect other children from what they
experience as children and that's why
they speak out
and that's why they go to the police
you know going to the police getting
Justice yes they'll give them some
healing some satisfaction but
they're overriding priority in most
cases is they want to protect other
children from going through the same
hell that they went through right and
these These are these are unsung heroes
these SRA survivors are unsung heroes
they should be recognized for their
courage and for their sacrifices for
other children
well you as well I mean you're your
courage has to be noted as well for
doing what you do and being outspoken
about
the research you've done on this and all
the victims you've talked to and trying
to get your your story and these victim
stories to reach as many people as
possible
um
what can be done
to
shed more light on this and get more
people to take this more seriously I
think
the message of
the evidence hot evidence being that
that SRA exists
so in the UK that hot evidence will
include the list of at least 10
successfully prosecuted SRA cases
I'm not saying this is an exhaustive
list there are probably other
successfully prosecuted SRA cases in the
UK that have not yet been added to the
list
uh the
the fact that the Metropolitan Police
Service
the largest and oldest police force in
the UK have publicly acknowledged the
existence of SRA
uh of satanic abuse on their website
we need to keep repeating this because
people seem to keep
overlooking this hard evidence
and claiming very falsely that there is
no evidence
of course there's evidence look at this
evidence the trouble is they don't
bother to stop and look at this evidence
which will only take a few minutes to
examine
and they will see the truth
foreign